on a sunny afternoon people here are
taking stock of Sunday's election it's
clear who the newspapers think is the
leading man now Sebastian courts faces a
choice of who to govern with to have
good talks with all the other parties in
the parliament and try to form a
government in Vienna people speculate
that might mean the Greens who muscled
their way back into Parliament with
their best-ever results and who might be
prepared to work with courts if he will
compromise we are well prepared for
these discussions and I can only say
that we will campaign for changes in
this country especially regarding
climate protection but also in terms of
integration that is the mandate that we
got unlike the far-right freedom party
whose vote chair plummeted due to the
corruption scandal its former leaders
caused in the spring seemingly
condemning their parliamentary
colleagues to a spell in opposition and
in effect meaning there are now no
far-right parties in government in much
of Western Europe some analysts believe
this absence from power may only be
temporary it will always be a roller
coaster they here to stay there will be
a huge market for right-wing populist
parties and because there is enough
anger and distrust in the population
with the political system to feed the
success of right-wing parties and yet
here in Austria that political tendency
is currently in check left to lick its
own self-inflicted wounds while it
watches its former partner bask in the
glow of electoral success for the past
four months this federal Chancellery has
been run by a caretaker government but
after Sunday's election result it's
pretty clear that no matter who
sebastian courts governs with he will be
the Chancellor dominic kane al jazeera
Vienna